joe rogan got quite a bit of heat
recently about mentioning a a paper
and a broader idea which i didn't i
don't think is that controversial but
maybe we can expand on it
and the idea is that
vaccines
create selective pressure
for a virus to mutate
and for variants to form
uh
first of all from a biological
perspective
can you explain this process and
from a
societal perspective what are we
supposed to do about that so let's get
the terminology right so as we talked
about earlier viruses are always
mutating
so no vaccine or no drug makes a virus
mutate right that's the wrong
perspective what you look at
what the what the
immune response is putting pressure
selection pressure on the virus and if
there's a
one particle with the right
mutation that can escape the antibody
that will emerge right
so that's what happens with influenza
virus right we vaccinate every year
and there are not a lot of people that
get infected so they get natural
immunity
and then the virus is incredibly
varied it mutates like crazy and there's
in some person somewhere there's one
variant that escapes the antibody which
has been induced either by infection or
vaccination it can be both
and that drives the emergence of the new
variant so the next year we need to
change the vaccine
so
i would say both natural infection and
vaccination sure
select for variance absolutely there's
no question because they're inducing
immunity now
what happened last year was
at the beginning of 2020 very few people
in the world were immune as the virus
first started spreading
but you can see in the sequences of
those isolates from the beginning of
2020 you can see
all of the changes that are now present
in the variants of concern at very very
low frequencies they were already there
but there was no
selection for them to emerge until
november when we now had many millions
of people who had
mostly been infected but also some
vaccinated then we saw the alpha variant
emerge in england probably because of
immune selection now the the virus that
had the change that evaded the antibody
had an advantage and that virus drove
through the population so that's what
we're seeing we're seeing all these
variants are simply antigenic selection
so so the the variance the mutations
that are at the core of these quantum
core variants
they were always there all along the
vaccine
or the infections did not create them no
the infections don't create they're
selected it's like the vaccine wipe out
a lot of the variants
right
and then um by being immune by making
your body immune to them and so but some
of them survive yeah and exactly and
there's another tree that's built
and it's unclear what that tree leads to
i mean it could make things much worse
or much better don't we don't know well
with flu we see year after year the
virus changes we change the vaccine we
deal with it we change it again there's
an unending but see that's a very
different story if do you think
do you think covid will be
um
with some likelihood
uh like the flu whereas basically
variants will never be able to um
eradicate it
you will never eradicate it
in any case
ever
well
come up with a vaccine that uh makes you
immune to enough variants to where
there's not enough evolutionary like
room well if you cut down the number of
infections then you reduce the diversity
sure yes right the problem is if let's
say
you're a cynic and you say well
vaccination is just selecting for
variance so let's stop it but then
you're going to have infection and
that's going to select for variance and
they're the more you're more likely to
get very sick because we know the
vaccines
are really good at preventing you from
dying so
that's why it still makes sense to use
vaccines because they prevent you from
dying yeah that's the bottom line but
can we ever make
a vaccine that deals
with all variants
absolutely and the reason i say that is
because
people who get
naturally infected with psoriasis they
develop covid they recover
if you give them one vaccine dose
they make an immune response that
handles
all the variants that are around right
now
all of them much better than people
who've gotten two doses of vaccine
for some reason
their immune response is suddenly
broadened after the infection
vaccination
and they can handle all the variants
that we know of so far so that tells me
we can
devise a strategy to do the same thing
with a vaccine that makes a really broad
vaccine that will handle all the very
well you actually
on the virology blog i don't know if
you're the author of that but i am
yes oh the blog yes but like there's a
particular post that's talking about
reporting in a paper
the mix and match strategy oh yes that's
one of my co-writers trudy ray yeah yeah
that's a it's an interesting idea that
there's some uh early evidence now that
uh mixing and matching vaccines like one
shot of pfizer and one of like modern or
something that creates a much better
uh immunity than uh does two shots of
laser i think that's worth exploring
absolutely
and this is relevant what we're doing
with influenza
you know instead of having to vaccinate
people every year why can't we devise a
vaccine which you'd get once in your
lifetime or maybe once every 10 years
okay
so
the the spike of influenza it's a long
protein kind of like the spike of saurus
cov2 it's stuck in the virus membrane in
the very tip
that's the part that changes
every year this is where the antibodies
bind
but the stem
doesn't change
and if you make antibodies to the stem
they can also prevent infection it's
just that
when people are infected or with the
current vaccines they'll make many
antibodies to that stem part but we're
trying to figure out how to make those
and we think they would be broadly
protective and you'd never be able to or
more rarely be able to
have a variant emerge that that escaped
it and i think we can do the same thing
with with coronavirus too for sure
you